Wesley as challenging as some of our
days might be with him I wouldn't want
to change him for the world because he
is just the happiest little thing
my name is Jim Baird and I am Tori Baird
we have two boys Wesley and Hudson
Wesley is just a little light for us
Wesley's non-verbal but yet he finds a
way to say so much just with his
expressions and his million dollar smile
[Music]
we noticed around four months Wesley
wasn't tracking with his eyes he's not
reaching for toys the way he typically
should be he's still not walking or
crawling or making really good eye
contact so we're kind of coming to our
own conclusion that obviously
something's going on here
we just felt like all this kind of joy
and the idea of how things were going to
be as new parents and all the hopes and
dreams we saw for our kid were replaced
with concern and worry and fear our
genetics counselor I remember her saying
the blood work came back and Wesley has
a syndrome called Fox G1 and she's like
how do you feel
and I remember thinking I don't know
what fox G1 is I have no idea what
you're saying to me and she kind of went
through her paperwork and explained it
to us
Fox G1 syndrome is a monogenic
neurodevelopmental disorder it is caused
by the mutation of the fox G1 Gene foxy
one gene is actually one of the first
and most critical genes in early brain
development I could feel my heart being
ripped out of my chest at this point and
I just remember sitting there with
Wesley on my lap and holding him Tighter
and Tighter
they give you this life-changing news
that they don't have very much
information about they don't know what
it could mean long term for Wesley what
his life is going to look like Jim was
driving and we had to pull over at one
point and just like cry and we're
Googling Fox G1 and I remember reading
what the symptoms are one of them was
uncontrollable laughter Wesley started
laughing in the back seat while Jim and
I are like horribly devastated and I
remember thinking maybe it's going to be
okay maybe this isn't so bad if one of
his symptoms is laughing you know
me and Tori just stood up straight and
looked at each other and just basically
said that it was going to be business as
usual I just looked at him and I told
him that he was going to be my best bud
no matter what it's not a super huge
community of people that have been
diagnosed with Fox G1 because it is
still fairly new as far as syndromes go
but there's likely more people out there
who have not been diagnosed we have a
little Facebook group of caregivers of
those with Fox G1 so we reach out to
each other and ask you deal with this
how do you deal with that and it's also
just nice to know that there are other
people out there who know what we're
going through and it gives us hope
one of the things that makes wessie the
happiest is when he hears all the birds
chirping and he just has a big smile on
his face we're lucky enough to have
those outdoor skills and knowledge being
in nature is good for anyone but it's
especially good for Wesley
Wesley became more aware of his
surroundings and that came with being
outdoors there's no cure for Fox G1
syndrome you could sink into a really
sad State when you get into that state
you're unable to find the energy to care
for your child who has disabilities
you're unable to take care of yourself
it's going to have its challenges but at
the end of the day you're gonna love
them anyways and they're going to teach
you so much every time you fall down
into these negative thoughts you have to
replace them with positive thoughts I
have confidence that Wesley is going to
progress and there might be more
treatments that could help Wesley that
his brother is going to be there to help
him and essentially they're going to
lead fulfilled lives and do good for the
world
[Music]
foreign